Stop worrying,
don't learn to live,
to love the bomb,
but stop worrying.
First of all,
Iran is so far away from having a
nuclear weapon.
Um,
I know there's all this reports,
these alarmist reports.
Iran has enough.
You rich uranium to build a bomb
tomorrow.
Well,
building a bomb is not as simple as it
sounds.
Yes,
the designs are on the Internet and you
can.
But to actually create a nuclear weapon
is going to be so difficult for Iran to
do quietly.
I'm secretly,
yes,
they have.
They've enriched uranium to three
percent or four percent.
Whatever the number is that is useful
for as fuel to then enrich it to 90
whatever percent they would have to.
I mean it would have to be done under
the watchful eyes of the IAEA,
so we would know about it the minute
they do it,
it's not like they have this other
secret facility or at least even the
IAEA doesn't think they have the secret
facility where they're doing exactly
what they're doing in front of the IAEA
and they can then secretly go out and in
and enrich to a higher level.
So once you've enriched it to a higher
level,
surely you'd want to test a nuclear
weapon before you just fired it off.
I mean,
it runs so far away from testing and
nuclear weapons.
So we wouldn't even know know the North
Koreans tested weapons and we don't,
we're not even sure that they worked.
Um,
we do know that Israel has nuclear
weapons.
We do know they have a delivery system
for those nuclear weapons.
They have the kinds of missiles that
could deliver accurate missiles that
could deliver nuclear weapons to Iran.
Iran is so far away from having that
ability.
Um,
some would say,
oh,
you're being naive.
They could do it in a year.
They could do it in two years.
But to be so many signals before that
happened that we could get,
we could become really alarmed if Iran
suddenly shuts down the IAEA cameras 24
hours a day on their facility where it's
using the riskier.
They shut down those cameras.
You can say,
okay,
that's the beginning of a cause of
alarm.
What are they doing that they want to
get rid of the IAEA inspectors?
So I mean,
we're so far away from that.
I think that we should let the AIAA do
their job.
We should at least talk to the Iranians.
I mean,
the thing is that they have the
technology to enrich uranium.
You're not going to bomb that technology
out of them.
There's plenty of people in Iran who can
start up a centrifuge program,
even if this program was completely
eliminated.
So the question now becomes,
how do we incentivize the Iranians to
never take that step?
We know that they have the knowledge to
build centrifuges,
to enrich uranium,
and a lot of people analyst will tell
you,
nuclear scientists will say it's not a
big step to then go to a bomb.
It is actually a bigger step than we
think because you have to test it.
You have to create that perfect sphere.
You have to have the mechanism,
you have to have the delivery system to
deliver it.
Presumably you want a second strike
capability,
not just a first strike capability,
because a first strike capability,
if somebody has a second strike on you,
you're done.
So you want to have this that to be an
equal in terms of nuclear power with
Israel for example.
So how do we incentivize them to not
take that step and that's where
negotiations come in because there are
plenty of countries that do have that
ability to.
Japan is one,
they're never incentivized to go and
build a bomb.
Brazil,
South Africa,
these are countries that have the
ability to enrich uranium,
have the ability to even probably build
a bomb if they want it to.
But what stops them from doing it?
Well,
there's,
they'd have no,
they have no incentive.
None whatsoever.
They have all the disincentives to build
a bomb.
So what we have to do is figure out
what,
how to disincentivize Iran from ever
taking that step.